Instructor: Let's
look at a couple more arrow-
function examples before we get
into talking about this. This is
something that comes up often
where I'm building an
application, and I don't
necessary have the data in the
right format that I want.
I'm building a website for a
bunch of racers, where this is
the first place, this is the
second place, and this is the
third place. These people have
been supplied to me in an array
of strings, and then they also
gave me a variable, which
includes the race that they won.
Ideally for me, I would have an
object which would have the
person's name, like Wes Boss. It
would have the place that they
won, like first place. Then it
would also have the race that
they won, which we could use the
race variable for that up here.
How would we do that? Well, we
can actually use Map again for
that. By the way, Map is not the
only function that arrow
functions work with. Arrow
functions work with anything,
and they're particularly useful
in these callback situations.
I'm going to say, "Constwin=
winners.map." I just want to
return an object from each of
those. I'm going to say, "winner."
How do you return an object? If
we're taking in a string, you
would return an object, like
this, where the name is the
winner and the race is the race,
and the place is going to be "I."
Also we're going to pass in the
index there, so that's two
arguments. We have to put
parentheses around that. That
should work, where we've got
this object here, but I don't
know if it's going to work.
Let's see. Unexpected token,
colon. What's wrong here? Well,
earlier we told you that if you
take the curly brackets off it's
an implicit return. How do you
implicit return curly brackets
when you mean for it to be an
object literal, not the actual
function block? What we can
do is, you just pass parentheses
around those. These parentheses
show that you're actually going
to return an object literal, and
these curly brackets aren't for
the actual function block, so
name is winner. Race is set to
the actual race variable we have
here, and then the place is
going to be set to the index.
You've got to save. We'll take a
look at our data. A little hot
tip, you refresh. You can type
in "win" to see all your objects,
but then you got to do all this
work on opening them up. What
you can actually do is use
console.table pass at win, and
look. You get this sweet-looking
table that will show you all the
information. There's the names.
There's the race. There's the
actual place. The problem
that we have here is that place
is zero-based obviously, because
your index is zero-based. We'll
probably have to say, "place
plus one." There we go. One, two,
three. Then the other thing,
we haven't learned about this
yet, but this "race race" looks
a little bit redundant. A new
feature of ES6 is you can just
use "race." That's the same
thing as saying, "race race."
Just say the variable race and
the property name race is all
named race. It's going to do it
just for us. There we go, so
that's an example of doing an
implicit return with an object
literal. There's another
example here where we poll the
people in the room for ages. So,
say constAge= ...Maybe someone's
23. Someone's 62. Just keep
going. Maybe someone's 234,
maybe someone's 2. You get the
point, right? Just make a whole
bunch of ages in the thing.
Maybe don't go that crazy.
We want to filter this list for
people who are older than 60
years old. How would you do that?
You say, "constOld=ages.filter,"
and then you get the age.
Normally you'd do something like, "
If the age is greater than 60,
return true." Since we can pass
it a condition that goes to true
or false, and filter will return
if it's true and it won't return
if it's false, we can just say, "
Age is greater or equal to 60."
That looks like a bit funky
because you got an arrow here
and then a greater than or equal
to 60 here, but what that will
do is, if the age is greater or
equal to 60, it will return true.
That age is going to be put back
into this new old array, which
is a console log old. See this
new array, 60? All the old
people are in this whereas none
of the young people are.